we've got some great questions this week
first one is from Nate Nate said hey
when did you realize you weren't a kid
anymore I have two types of answer for
this one is more in terms of
responsibilities the other is more of a
physical thing
I once sneezed while sort of angled
weirdly and it caused me to basically
have neck pain for a week and at that
point I realized I'm probably starting
to get old and now whenever I sneeze I
make sure that I'm not in any kind of
angled position that might make my head
snap at a weird angle and I look
straight ahead when I sneeze now that
was probably a sign where I was like
yeah little now I understand why when
you fall as an adult it's not like when
you fall as a kid who thought that
sneezing could be such a coming-of-age
mom I know and I'm sure you had to
sneeze at that awkward angle because
maybe you were being considerate of
everyone else around you naturally you
may not show that same consideration
when you're just a few years old that's
true too yeah the fact that I found it
so important not to sneeze on other
people was probably also a sign now I'm
sure that as a result of that it's
clearly evidence of me being a beta male
cuck iReal because only beta male cucks
would ever hurt their necks by sneezing
but hey this is full honesty and
transparency
unless that wasn't about to be leaked by
the New York Times so I didn't do like
the Trump jr. thing where now I'll be
transparent about it that was one that I
could have kept secret for a long time
but I'm sharing it with you in the
audience from a responsibility
perspective I think that there were
numerous instances one was when I had a
some kind of financial thing happened
with a wire that I sent and then it
wasn't received and it was related to
some service I had and then like the
service was going to get cancelled and
it was like wow yeah there's no more
sort of like parent around I'm sort of
like on my own with this when I was like
21 or something like that and then
that's just been a process of sort of
like hey I'm responsible for my own
health insurance now I'm no longer on my
parent's health insurances financially I
think there's a lot of moments at which
you sort of realized oh yeah I'm not a
kid anymore
I felt this way when I was 18 and being
dropped off at college because I
remember my parents drove me out there
with all of my stuff and we went out to
lunch and I was just thinking you know
they're just gonna leave and I'm going
to be here in the city on my own I can
pretty much do whatever I want I get to
meet all these new people and yes you
know you're only 18 you still are fully
reliant on them at that age most people
are anyway but I felt that way for sure
well another one for me that's college
related is every year I go back a couple
times and will lecture in some class at
my undergraduate alma mater the
University of Massachusetts the freshmen
look like little kids now they really
and that and that at first I was like
yeah I'm 20 to 23 everybody still sort
of looks the same age I'm 24 or 25 yeah
if I show up at a bar I'm not really
noticeably older these people sort of
still look like my peers now when I show
up and I see 18 year old freshmen they
look like little kids
and that I think is a testament to the
fact that I'm not a kid anymore well
maybe we're just aging at a slower rate
you know life expectancies are going up
you have to imagine that we're not
showing signs of ages early anymore
another one would be meeting people and
very quickly noticing whether or not
they have a wedding band on and just
sort of like it's all over that now it's
so common that people that I meet that
are my age are married that I very
quickly look at that in addition to
whatever else you might look at to
figure out sort of like oh what what is
it what would deal with this person type
of thing that's interesting because my
friends wouldn't I will have these
conversations about you know you want to
pick up a girl you got to make sure that
she doesn't have a wedding band on
you're right on her finger that's the
age that you got to start looking out
for those things absolutely absolutely
so anyway those are some thoughts
there's probably others I think I think
that there's a more more than I'm
skipping but those are some of the some
of the main ones good one Nate comment
by the way if you're watching on YouTube
or if you're listening go to YouTube and
leave a comment on this video with when
you realize you weren't a kid anymore
unless you still are because we actually
do have a lot of people under 18 who
watch the show